what's up everybody aaron sampson here
with david ahmadi
what happened there oh my god we weren't
trying to test that
okay
i'm just i'm just gonna call the test
and then i'll call it confirmed
can you be killed by the the decapitated
flying turret of a tank
that is confirmed that is awesome i
can't believe that happened we're here
doing more battlefield tests we had a
really good time making this and you all
had some great suggestions so hit that
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and
tell us in the comments what's the next
thing you want to see us try all right
let's go
so david uh i played a lot of just cause
3
back in the day you know i played the
whole just cause series and there's
something you can do in the just cause
series which doesn't make any damn sense
but it's hilarious you can break your
fall by shooting the ground
while you're falling so here's the test
we're gonna test if you can break your
fall
while jumping to the ground by grabbing
the ground because it makes perfect
sense all right ready
with the grapple hook yeah with the grab
look i'm gonna go behind you ready three
two one jump
oh wow
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so confirm you can actually break
your fall by shooting the ground and
grappling to it with the grapple hook
but is it faster to just not do it is it
faster to get to the ground by grappling
which should give you momentum or by
just jumping so let's go side by side
ready
so we're gonna we're gonna grapple from
here oh yeah
we're gonna grapple basically from here
to the ground yep uh you're gonna
grapple you're gonna jump and grapple
and i'm just gonna jump
okay ready
yep three two one go
[Music]
yeah i am still gracefully just
i'm gracefully floating down
it's like such a graceful descent it's
kind of like just it's it's like the
opposite of just cause 2 where it
totally works in a pinch um
but it's honestly better to not do it
it's just kind of physics yeah
okay so for our next test what we want
to see is if there are things that can
go through dozer shield in our previous
test we went ahead and we we fired a
rocket and show that that clearly does
not go through the shield we also tried
things like tanks but uh some of you in
the comments said that the under braille
grenade launcher goes through so let's
try this does the underbarrel grenade
launcher go through dozer shield
no
not only does it not go through the
shield that is busted it it comes back
at you
i think somebody can see it hit my
shield it just looks like it drops in
front of you it's so crazy okay but we
did want to test one other thing these
are both user suggested comments so we
discovered there is back blast
in in our last episode so is my what
does it look like from your perspective
is my rocket coming through your shield
or right on it
uh it is it is red on it if i like push
into it a little bit yeah it's still
just on it okay so if you come up
against dozer and rockets don't work
we'll back blast work testing in three
two one
oh that's like 50 damage
firing again
three two one
there you go
confirmed but it takes two shots and i
don't think you're gonna have that long
yeah it's a reload
so the next one we want to test if
there's anything you can do to get rid
of peg's scan once she's pinged you
can smoke grenades get rid of it
and move
nope you're definitely getting pain so
smoke grenades
smoke grenades don't get rid of the skin
so that's busted there's really nothing
you can do
so far other than just get out of cover
to break that scan
but in which case once you're out of
cover
they already kind of know where you're
coming from so
i think you're kind of screwed a lot of
you might have noticed that in the
advertisements irish had a grenade
interceptor it took me damn near forever
to figure out how to actually do it
because of the amount of controls in
this game but if you just sort of click
on the button that gets you the shield
uh you can go ahead and select it and
drop it you can drop up two of them what
we really want to test though is what it
actually stops so it says it stops
explosive projectiles so let's start
with grenades go ahead and toss a
grenade at me
yep
oh yeah big time stopped your girl
was that a cluster grenade
uh okay cluster grenade let me make sure
i got the right
one okay here comes the scatter grenade
wow
okay try uh let's let's up our game a
little bit try rocket
rockets
nope
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's really funny the timing of that
was kind of insane all right we're gonna
try this one again and stand by
okay so in that last round i got
straight blown um out of the round so
we're gonna try again with the rocket go
ahead and fire it past me this time and
we'll test whoa
it stopped it one more time uh shoot it
at me though
yeah
so confirmed irish's interceptor stops
grenades and recoilless rifle
projectiles and for the people out there
i know i said rocket a few times but the
gustav is a recoilless rifle let's up
our game a little bit and go go to a
tank i'm gonna i'm gonna back up because
i don't know what's gonna happen here
let's go
tank versus irishes uh shoot down
sentinel hit it all right i'm gonna
shoot a little bit past you see what
happens
oh nothing
that's considered a projectile but not
an explosive projectile so that's
probably why
did i shoot you
uh
okay
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i mean yeah this is gonna be
a gg i think
it does not stop tank rounds i realized
we got to try one more thing
uh the main gun round from a tank
obviously wasn't stopped we don't have a
tow missile so we'll go ahead and test
uh helicopter rockets i'm gonna step a
step aside here and go ahead and fire
one ready right about there we'll see if
our piloting skills are so bad
i'm just i'm not even going to lie to
this audience okay so see
so see if you can put some rockets right
here
it stopped one of them
yeah no totally did fire again uh it
doesn't stop all of them it just stops
every like
couple
okay so that's sad
partly confirmed um but also not
effective i i would say if it's a
helicopter okay so we did notice that a
lot of you are having trouble with
hovercraft and there's something we just
kind of wanted to test here
it seems like a lot of players or at
least a lot of newer players don't
realize that you can shoot through the
hovercraft windows
uh so what we're gonna test here is can
you shoot through the hovercraft windows
with anything or is it just some weapons
so why don't you go ahead and get in the
in the main gun
this is a lot more obvious with other
vehicles because you can see into them
so the back gun oh you know what i like
i didn't even know this is the first
time i've actually been this close to it
so
check this out so the person is actually
sitting inside the hovercraft in kind of
the back right position or back left
that's interesting what'd you just
switch to there which gun i just
switched to the so i was the left gunner
so i'm the left gunner right now here
yeah and then i just swap to the right
gunner now okay and what's the top gun
top gunner is here oh wow okay
so you should know this you know when
you're playing this game when somebody's
in the hovercraft shooting they're
actually physically switching between
these different seats so let's start
with pistol and um
first test
okay so that just straight up goes right
through uh why don't you go back to one
of the other guns
yeah i'm going to the left gun now
okay
so if they're on the left gun
facing you they're on the same side and
you can get them like let me go through
the side window
so yeah you can go it's deceptive but
you can go right through that window go
to the right gun
so that's confirmed even even
even with a pistol you can actually get
through the hovercraft let me let me try
the side armor though so which side are
you on
i'm still on the right side now
okay so you cannot get through
that side armor
let me try a grenade
okay so confirmed any weapon can get
through the glass at least
and just remember these positions where
people are in the hovercraft let me try
one more time with armor-piercing rounds
i'll be back in one second
all right
coming in in style all right i got some
armor-piercing rounds on the believe
it's the m5a3 so we can try and see if
this works out let me see where you're
at okay let me swap
all right armor piercing is loaded in
and
oh yeah yeah
yeah 100 oh big time
150
so that is confirmed you can get through
the side panel with armor-piercing
rounds and you can get through any of
the front panels with anything else
including a pistol okay so the next test
i was gonna actually do with um both of
us but i realized because we're on
opposite teams we can't so i'm just
going to say this one and show you guys
the footage um we wanted to test like
the range that you can get revived at
and whether you can get revived through
buildings and here's that clip which is
confirmed you can actually revive people
through walls or at least through the
floors of buildings so keep that in mind
when you're fighting in these types of
containers okay for this next test
i've been really curious if you could
drop ranger
in the back of a flatbed truck
and drive around with it like you know
and like there's some things you can get
into the back of a flatbed truck some
some gadgets can definitely get there um
but i don't know about ranger i've
always wanted to try this you can't do
it with the
like the faster vehicle so let's give it
a try um
and if i miss david you can give it a
try
careful because that ranger is going to
be
real mad at you oop no it's behind
back up oh you got it you got it you got
it you got it
stay stay
good boy
uh he seems confused
this good boy seems kind of confused
[Laughter]
we're going to call that one busted just
because you can but ranger ranger did
not stay in the back of the truck like a
good boy all right folks there's a quick
lightning round of things we want people
to
know in this one these are things that
took me way too long to learn and i
think they're going to help you out a
lot so the first one is the the g17
actually has a burst fire a lot of
people don't know this if you're on
controller so you have to actually aim
down sight and then change to burst you
can't just do it uh when you're not ads
so that took me way too long to figure
out so single fire
and burst fire that's one everybody
should know about
the next one that everybody should know
about you do not have to re-kit your
weapon from the plus system every round
the very first ring in the plus system
is what your weapon takes so if you
switch it to say suppressor here you
will spawn in with that suppressor on
stock you don't have to redo it every
round
all right and the final tip is we're
gonna test out if ranger will count as a
plus one when you're capping an
objective so i'm gonna call a ranger
down i am standing way back given how
aggressive yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you're gonna want to take cover
i'm gonna try and distract ranger and
get him to come my way yep yeah yeah
that is confirmed for sure the number
says uh it says two on my team yeah it
says one v2 so that is confirmed ranger
is
counted as plus one don't come my way
ranger rangers count it don't get my way
ranger
get cast
ranger does count as a plus one when
you're capturing an objective confirmed
and on that pandemonium thank you so
much for watching our episode of the
things that we had to test in
battlefield 2042 this game is busted but
i think david and i just are finding our
own fun in this game and finding ways to
enjoy it so just keep coming back head
on over to gamespot.com head over to
gamespot's youtube page and we will keep
testing battlefield as long as you guys
want to keep watching it all right thank
you so much everyone you can use my help
i should have brought health facts for
you
no ranger bad boy bad rager
the only thing i can think of is no
rager bad ranger
why are you so angry
ranger just wakes up every day and
chooses violence